thank you for joining us i'm john
langler this afternoon at northwest
valley thai restaurant is closed for
lunch it's under investigation after
reports from some customers that they
ate thc tainted food there last week
bianca holman is live at the business
with reaction from those who work nearby
bianca
yes we spoke with a couple of business
owners in this shopping center and they
said that they are disappointed to hear
about what happened at the now closed
secret of siam restaurant here in the
northwest part of town so the eatery has
been closed since monday metro along
with the health district are
investigating multiple reports about
adulterated food law enforcement was
seen overnight at the restaurant several
customers who ate the food from the
restaurant over the weekend claimed the
food sent them to the hospital
they claimed that the food was laced
with thc and the which is the main
psychoactive compound in cannabis brock
howard owns a business nearby he says
he's eaten at the time spot and is
shocked to hear about this situation
i was surprised because i've never had
that experience there from business
owner aspect i mean what's going on you
know because we know you're trying to
put the best product out there and you
know a product that people want and then
having that come back on you having
saying that there could be possible it's
scary
so in order for the restaurant to reopen
the southern nevada health district
would have to approve and also we're
told by the health district that other
agencies are involved bianca coleman
live local now